[Music]
people are still talking about the
nightmare trip on carnival cruise ships
triumph
uh well many passengers who were
stranded for four days in filthy and
unsanitary conditions on the ship are
now and you can guess what was coming
starting to file absolutely lawsuits
they're all filing lawsuits well here's
the strange thing the latest lawsuit is
by someone who wasn't even on the ship
yeah we actually have the plaintiff live
via satellite from a manhattan law
office where he's about to hold a press
conference
and uh there he is
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen hi triumph hello
conan okay and uh i understand that is
your attorney with you that is alan
dershowitz
yes yes i'm uh
here with uh he's my attorney a long
time friend you probably remember him
from the oj trial he's a true american
hero yes thank you triumph thank you
very much all right now i understand
triumph that you have a prepared
statement you want to read
yes
worst puppeteering i've ever seen
you okay triumph you all right over
there i'm perfect don't worry about me
all right this is the list of my
problems all right
what is your complaint triumph
ladies and gentlemen
members of the media
thank you for coming here
today recently the carnival cruise lines
use the name triumph
without my permission
on their disastrous crews
by doing so
they have degraded my good name
and cast negative aspersions on my
persona
it's very distressing
from now on
people will only associate me
with poop
yeah
i have spent many years
building a career and a reputation
and now suddenly
people are coming up to me everywhere
and saying hey triumph that's a great
ship for you to poop on
okay actually triumph to be fair you
know
therefore i'm suing
the carnival cruise lines for the sum
of
900 million dollars okay try them
triumph i'm sorry to interrupt but
haven't people been saying for me to
poop on to you for years ago conan conan
that is an ancillary issue this is about
present circumstances since the incident
i mean this is a prima facie case that
relies on the law of resips a locator as
it relates to the rule of labia majora
carnival's negligence has caused
irreparable damage to micro back to my
close-up
i want to see your show
[Applause]
and place tremendous stress on my family
and also on my call girl
romeo
when an organization
when an organization chooses
to use the name triumph i'm sorry excuse
me excuse me mr dershowitz why are you
holding those papers to your face
conan please i'm i'm merely scanning my
notes which clearly cite the precedent
of gluteus maximus and hakuna matata
yeah so leave us alone crash bandicoot
[Laughter]
to use the name triumph
they have a responsibility to uphold the
high standards i have set
but instead
they smeared
than just my name
[Applause]
the last time i saw people
the last time i saw people
my close-up
the last time i saw people covered in
that much feces they were touring the
white house with al roker
one thing is for certain
the shopping on board the triumph was
definitely not
conan are you ready you know what's
coming yeah
international waters
duty-free
[Applause]
it's a good one
[Music]
by day three the cruise ship had clearly
entered
uncharted territory
uh
conan a chart is when an individual uh
is under the presumption that he has
passed gas i know we know but uh okay
it's okay thank you that's good
even worse
one passenger's room was flooded with
nicholas cage movies
[Applause]
tragedy
folks if i wanted four days worth of
i'd give chris christie a laxative
by the way
if anyone filmed what was happening on
that ship
the entire country of germany would like
to have a copy
those poor poor people
on that cruise ship
all they wanted was a trip to mexico
and all they got were overflowing
toilets unsanitary conditions and power
outages
in other words
a threat to mexico
brian i'm sorry i have to tell you i
think this lawsuit is a really stupid
idea no one cares what you think freckle
dick
stupid idea
stupid idea i'm so sorry it's not as
smart as talking to snooki and jay wow
for 10 minutes
[Applause]
triumph the insult coming down everybody